los versos del Corán que mencionan la yihad o la lucha
no anulan los versos que hablan del perdón,
de benevolencia
o de paciencia.
Pero creo que ahora no hay ninguna circunstancia
que justifique la yihad violenta,
porque implicará un daño mayor.
Pero ahora la idea de yihad ha sido manipulada.
Su significado ha sido distorsionado para indicar una lucha violenta
dondequiera que los musulmanes estén pasando por momentos difíciles
y transformada en terrorismo
por islamitas fascistas como Al Qaeda,
el Estado Islámico y otros.
Pero yo he llegado a comprender
que la verdadera yihad significa esforzarse al máximo
para fortalecer y vivir aquellas cualidades que le agradan a Dios:
la honestidad, la lealtad,
la compasión, la bondad,
la confianza, el respeto,
la autenticidad...
valores humanos que muchos compartimos.
Nací en Bangladesh,
pero crecí sobre todo en Inglaterra.
Y fui a la escuela aquí.
Mi padre era profesor universitario
y vivíamos en el Reino Unido gracias a su trabajo.
En 1971 estábamos en Bangladesh, cuando todo cambió.
La Guerra de Independencia nos afectó terriblemente,
enfrentando familias contra familias
y vecinos contra vecinos.
Con 12 años ya pasé por la experiencia de una guerra,
pobreza económica,
la muerte de 22 de mis familiares,
así como el asesinato de mi hermano mayor.
Presencié matanzas,
vi animales comiendo cadáveres en las calles,
hambruna a mi alrededor,
violencia horrible y gratuita...
violencia sin sentido.
Era joven,
un adolescente, fascinado por las ideas.
Quería aprender,
pero no pude ir a la escuela durante 4 años.
Tras la Guerra de Independencia,
mi padre fue enviado a la cárcel durante 2 años y medio.
Solía ir a visitarlo una vez a la semana
y estudiaba solo en casa.
Mi padre fue liberado en 1973
y huyó a Inglaterra como refugiado;
pronto lo seguimos.
Yo tenía 17 años.
Así que gracias a estas experiencias tomé conciencia repentinamente
de las atrocidades y las injusticias en el mundo.
Y tenía un fuerte deseo
--un deseo ávido y profundo--
de hacer justicia
y ayudar a los oprimidos.
Mientras iba a la universidad en el Reino Unido,
conocí a gente que me enseñó cómo podía canalizar ese deseo
y ayudar a través de mi religión.
Y fui radicalizado...
lo suficiente como para creer que la violencia era el camino correcto,
incluso una virtud en ciertas circunstancias.
Así empecé a involucrarme en la yihad en Afganistán.
Quería proteger a la población afgana musulmana
contra el ejército soviético.
Y creía que aquello era yihad:
mi deber sagrado
que sería recompensado por Dios.
Me hice predicador.
Fui uno de los pioneros de la yihad violenta en el Reino Unido.
Reclutaba,
recaudaba fondos, entrenaba.
Confundí la verdadera yihad
con esta perversión que nos vendían los islamistas fascistas...
esta gente que utiliza la idea de yihad
para justificar su ansia de poder, autoridad y control sobre el mundo:
una perversión perpetuada hoy por grupos islamistas fascistas
como Al Qaeda, el Estado Islámico y otros.
Durante unos 15 años,
luché brevemente
en Cachemira y Burma, aparte de Afganistán.
Nuestro objetivo era eliminar a los invasores,
aliviar a las víctimas oprimidas
y, por supuesto, fundar un estado islámico,
un califato para la ley de Dios.
Y lo hacía abiertamente.
No infringía ninguna ley.
Estaba orgulloso y agradecido de ser británico...
y lo sigo siendo.
Y no sentía ninguna hostilidad contra este país mío,
ni enemistad contra los ciudadanos no musulmanes
y sigue siendo así.
Durante una batalla en Afganistán,
algunos británicos y yo entablamos una amistad especial
con un chico afgano de 15 años,
Abdullah,
un niño inocente, cariñoso y adorable
que siempre estaba deseoso de complacer.
Era pobre.
Los chicos como él hacían recados en el campamento.
Y parecía bastante feliz,
pero no podía parar de pensar...
sus padres deben de haberlo echado mucho de menos.
Y deben de haber soñado con un futuro mejor para él.
Una víctima de las circunstancias, atrapada en una guerra,
impuesta cruelmente
por las atroces circunstancias del tiempo.
Un día recogí una granada de mortero en una trinchera
y la dejé en un laboratorio improvisado en una cabaña de barro.
Y salí a un breve, inútil enfrentamiento,
siempre inútiles.
Volví unas horas más tarde y descubrí que había muerto.
Había intentado recuperar explosivos de ese proyectil.
Le explotó y falleció de una muerte violenta,
despedazado por el mismo dispositivo que había resultado inofensivo para mí.
Así que empecé a preguntarme.
¿De qué ha servido su muerte?
¿Por qué murió él y yo no?
Seguí adelante.
Luché en Cachemira.
También recluté gente en Filipinas,
Bosnia y Chechenia.
Y las dudas fueron aumentando.
Más tarde en Burma,
me topé con guerrilleros rohingya
apenas adolescentes,
nacidos y criados en la jungla,
y que llevaban ametralladoras y lanzagranadas.
Conocí a dos chicos de 13 años delicados y con voces suaves.
Me miraron y me suplicaron que los llevara a Inglaterra.
Solo querían ir a la escuela...
ese era su sueño.
Mi familia
--mis hijos de la misma edad--
estaban en casa, en el Reino Unido,
iban a la escuela,
tenían una vida segura.
Y no podía dejar de imaginar
cuánto estos chicos debían de haber hablado entre ellos
acerca de sus deseos de tener una vida así.
Víctimas de las circunstancias:
estos dos chicos jóvenes,
durmiendo sobre la dura tierra, mirando las estrellas,
cínicamente explotados por sus líderes
por su anhelo personal de gloria y poder.
Pronto vi chicos así matarse entre ellos
en conflictos entre grupos rivales.
Y era lo mismo por doquier:
Afganistán, Cachemira, Burma,
Filipinas, Chechenia;
mezquinos señores de la guerra incitaban a los jóvenes y vulnerables
a matarse el uno al otro en el nombre de yihad.
Musulmanes contra musulmanes.
No protegían a nadie contra los invasores o los ocupantes;
no ayudaban a los oprimidos.
Utilizaban a los niños,
los explotaban cínicamente;
la gente moría en conflictos
que yo estaba apoyando en el nombre de la yihad.
Y sigue ocurriendo lo mismo.
Tras comprender que la yihad violenta
a la que me había dedicado en el extranjero
era tan diferente
--un abismo tal entre lo que había vivido
y lo que creía ser un deber sagrado--
tuve que reflexionar sobre mis actividades aquí en el Reino Unido.
Tuve que reconsiderar mi predicación,
reclutamiento, recaudación de fondos,
entrenamiento,
pero sobre todo la radicalización
--el enviar a jóvenes a luchar y morir
como estaba haciendo--
todo estaba completamente equivocado.
Me involucré en la yihad violenta a mediados de los 80,
empezando con Afganistán.
Y para cuando acabé, ya era el año 2000.
Estaba completamente inmerso en ello.
A mi alrededor la gente apoyaba,
aplaudía,
incluso celebraba lo que hacíamos en su nombre.
Pero para cuando conseguí dejarlo,
completamente desilusionado en el año 2000,
ya habían pasado 15 años.
Entonces, ¿en qué nos equivocamos?
Estábamos tan ocupados hablando de virtud
que nos obnubiló una causa.
Y no nos dimos la oportunidad de desarrollar un carácter virtuoso.
Nos convencimos de que estábamos luchando por los oprimidos,
pero esas eran guerras imposibles de ganar.
Nos convertimos en el mismo instrumento que causaba más muertes,
cómplices de provocar más miseria
por el beneficio egoísta de una minoría cruel.
Así que con el tiempo,
después de mucho tiempo,
abrí los ojos.
Empecé a atreverme
a enfrentarme a la verdad,
a pensar,
a encarar las preguntas difíciles.
Conecté con mi alma.
¿Qué aprendí?
Que la gente que se involucra en el yihadismo violento,
que la gente que se siente atraída por ese tipo de extremismos,
no es tan diferente a los demás.
Pero creo que gente así puede cambiar.
Pueden recuperar sus corazones y regenerarlos,
llenándolos con valores humanos que curan.
Cuando ignoramos las realidades,
descubrimos que aceptamos lo que nos dicen
sin reflexión crítica.
E ignoramos los regalos y las ventajas que muchos de nosotros apreciarían
incluso por un solo momento en sus vidas.
Estuve involucrado en acciones que consideraba justas.
Pero ahora he empezado a cuestionarme cómo sabía lo que sabía.
Decía continuamente a todos que aceptaran la verdad,
pero no dejé espacio para la duda.
Esta convicción de que la gente puede cambiar
está arraigada en mi experiencia,
mi proprio recorrido.
A través de la lectura,
la reflexión,
la contemplación, el autoconocimiento,
descubrí, me di cuenta, de que el mundo de los islamistas
del nosotros y ellos es falso e injusto.
Analizando las incertidumbres
en todas las verdades que habíamos declarado inviolables,
indiscutibles,
desarrollé una comprensión más flexible.
Me di cuenta de que en un mundo atestado de diferencias y contradicción,
los predicadores insensatos,
solo los predicadores insensatos como solía ser yo,
no ven la ironía en los mitos y las ficciones
que utilizan para afirmar legitimidad.
Así que comprendí la importancia vital del autoconocimiento,
de la conciencia política
y de la necesidad de una profunda y amplia comprensión
de nuestros compromisos y nuestras acciones,
y de cómo afectan a los demás.
Así que hoy ruego a todos,
sobre todo a los que sinceramente creen en el yihadismo islamista:
rechacen la autoridad dogmática;
abandonen la ira, el odio y la violencia;
aprendan a hacer justicia
sin siquiera intentar justificar el comportamiento cruel, injusto y fútil.
Creen a cambio cosas bonitas y útiles
que nos sobrevivan.
Aproxímense al mundo, a la vida,
con amor.
Aprendan a desarrollar
o entrenar sus corazones
para que vean la bondad, la belleza y la verdad en los demás y en el mundo.
Así sí seremos relevantes para nosotros mismos,
el uno para el otro,
para nuestras comunidades
y, en mi caso, para Dios.
Esto es yihad...
mi verdadera yihad.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)